füle carmen la femme fatale
une femme fière et sensuelle oeuvres
majeures de georges bizet l'une des plus
jouées au monde choisi par les clés
lyrique le fait que ce soit un opéra qui
est extrêmement culte c'est vraiment le
genre d'opéra que les amateurs et pas
les experts c'est à dire qui voit là
c'est vraiment pour tout le monde c'est
un peu comme une opérette s'offrait un
peu plus sérieux ça touche à des choses
plus profondes et les morceaux sont
absolument splendide
[Musique]
sur scène une vingtaine d'amateurs une
année de travail pour raconter les
amours tumultueuses de donne josé carmen
j'ai ordonné le personnage de carmen
dodgers et c'est extraordinaire et le
plus quand on
plus qu'on creuse dans ses oeuvres le
plus qu'on peut trouver c'est quelqu'un
à quelque chose qui est que son sein on
dit que c'est le premier femmes libres
dans l'histoire de l'opéra libre de son
esprit libre dans son corps et c'est ça
qui gênait horriblement 2h15 de
spectacles pour plonger dans le civil du
début du 19e siècle et découvrir
d'autres titres de ce célèbre opéra